[inaudible]
joining me today as a student and activist and the director of high school
outreach for turning point USA.
Kyle,
because you have,
welcome to the Rubin report.
Thanks for having me on.
I am excited to have you here.
We've met a couple times,
we've done some events together.
You are seemingly wise beyond your years.
Nice.
That's true.
All right,
let's get to it.
Well actually,
I mean in a weird way,
I guess you've been,
you've been sort of thrust into being wise beyond your years.
You are obviously a,
a survivor of the parkland shooting.
Uh,
as you know,
I had your classmate,
camera and Cassidy,
I'm a couple of weeks ago and he kind of laid out,
uh,
what happened to him that day and subsequently everything that's happened.
So let's just start there because that's kind of what put you on the map.
Okay.
I'll sort of preface it.
Um,
I don't like try to,
I don't like to refer myself as a survivor because I wasn't in the building that
will shut into.
And I think that,
you know,
cheapens the of pain and tragedy that people who were in the building.
Uh,
so what happened with me that day,
it was fourth period.
Uh,
I was in,
I was in my fourth period class,
uh,
and all of a sudden the alarms a ring.
So we go into the hallway and we're walking out and we hear two,
like two little,
uh,
pops.
I don't know if two textbooks fell,
no fire,
fire works.
I really had no idea.
So we run back,
uh,
and I go and reach for,
for the,
uh,
the door to my classroom and the,
the teacher locked it.
So you go into a nearby room,
we get in there and we just hide a for two hours straight.
We just hear pops in ambulances.
I ended up,
so that was the freshman building.
And the entire time we had no idea what was going on.
Uh,
and then all throughout the entire time people,
uh,
immediately or just villainizing guns.
You know,
the second we got a second I got out of the,
uh,
the closet that I was in.
Kids are like,
we have to ban any our fifteens
yeah,
let's not jump into the political party cause it's interesting just listening to
you hear about that.
It's almost like the way you were describing it almost sounds like you weren't
even there.
Like it's just like a story that you were telling,
you know,
in a bizarre way.
So once,
okay,
so all of this happens,
you find out now they're,
they're dead students.
I mean,
did you have friends who were killed?
And
so we get it,
we get out of the closet.
Swat takes us out.
They put their,
you know,
air fifteens and our faces take us out.
We have to put our hands on the person in front of us walking outside and all
throughout this,
the most disgusting thing was every single corner of the entire block
surrounding us was just filled with media cars.
It was just like jam packed.
And what I saw there was that whenever there was like someone crying or like a
moment of pain,
the media would just surround them in a capsulate them.
Uh,
and I,
I got home and I was really hoping that this wouldn't be like a politicized
spectacle with like mass,
uh,
you know,
media jumping the gun to everything.
Uh,
and sadly that was the case.
So when I was like sitting there in shock,
seeing the numbers rise on the screens for the death count,
it was like so insane to internalize like what it just occurred.
Because like,
everyone's always,
you know,
this will never to my school.
How could this happen to my school?
Uh,
and the sad reality is it can happen with any school.
Like,
I mean,
Stoneman Douglas was in the most affluent,
low crime,
you know,
city I think in like southern Florida.
And this happened at our school.
Did you know some of the kids that were killed?
Yeah,
I knew one girl.
Hold on.
Uh,
uh,
she was in a class of mine year back.
Yeah.
So what kind of time did you guys have to grieve?
Because that you're,
you're already alluding to this,
but it was like,
it was as if the event happened,
the shooting happened and then it seemingly,
there was no grieving and then you guys were all over the television.
You were all over Twitter,
you at all political people using you guys and all sorts of different ways.
Just tell me a little bit about just kind of the grieving and trying to be able
to be,
how old do you know you're 17 trying to be 1615 1617 year old kids trying to
just survive something unimaginably horrible.
Yeah.
I don't know how freshmen and sophomores have managed to go through this.
Like I'm at least a junior.
I was a junior at the time,
so I knew the school had a better in like somewhat of my self esteem was a
little more build up more and a little bit more mature.
Uh,
but there was absolutely no time to grieve whatsoever.
Like a few days after the shooting,
they already bust this up to Tallahassee to,
you know,
kind of like push to like tug on the emotional heartstrings of Republicans to
pass legislation that they otherwise wouldn't have passed.
Who,
who is they in that equation?
So there are some,
uh,
members,
in the Florida Senate,
uh,
that like personally like coordinated buses,
um,
from Parkland to Tallahassee.
Yeah.
And what were your parents saying or the friends,
you know,
friends,
parents,
like it just seemed like the parents were almost gone now.
Now there are some of the parents that are a little more high profile that I,
that I see.
But it was as if you guys were just like taken,
that's what it felt like.
Suddenly we're seeing you on CNN and town halls and I want to talk a little bit
about that.
But just like that you were just used all over the place with not even having a
moment to just digest
what happened.
So,
so here's how I don't think that necessarily.
so here's what I think what happened.
I think that the kids saw what happened.
They were shocked as they should be.
And I decided attack,
like we said,
this can't happen to anyone else ever again.
Let's do something,
you know,
what really occurred is that the mainstream media jumped,
jumped on this immediately,
uh,
and just like put it to like a national scale and,
and really used it to push a gun control agenda.
And that's why I started speaking out because I want it to represent the other
side of stone Douglas who doesn't believe in gun control.
Yeah.
So just tell me a little bit about you in high school before this.
Like we've jumped the line.
What was Kyle,
cause you have like,
before this,
cause I know you sort of as a political beast now in like a wickedly incisive
Twitter and like,
you know,
you've put on events that I've been part of and I,
and you're incredibly organized and connecting with great people and all that
stuff,
which is,
tell me about the kid before that.
I'll give you all the recap.
We'll give me the story of my life story.
Let's go.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
so my parents,
came from Israel.
They immigrated here.
My Dad,
my mom served the IDF.
Uh,
they came here,
there's nothing worked their way up.
Uh,
and then when I was,
when I was at home,
they taught me Hebrew and English.
So we only spoke Hebrew at home.
So I'm fluent in Hebrew and they put me through school and I was always the
shortest kid in the grade.
So I was like always like,
I was just like even shorter than the shortest girl in my grade.
I was like super short and like,
what was it like in like eighth grade?
I was four foot eight.
I was like legally images in eighth grade.
So I'll,
I got bullied a lot.
Like I try not to have a victimhood mentality cause I don't think it's
successful and I think you agree with me on that.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Um,
so always,
always bullied and I was always,
I was always smart,
so that kind of went back on me a little bit,
but I was always put a lot and it built up my self esteem.
Uh,
in addition,
I was always like taking the hardest classes.
My parents would always push me to take the hardest classes possible.
Um,
so at Douglas,
before all this,
uh,
you know,
I somewhat of,
I had a good social life.
Uh,
so I would basically,
I would go to school,
do my AP classes,
go home,
play video games.
So like 10,
10:00 PM start homework to like start homework,
you know,
and then finish it at 2:00 AM and then have like five hours of sleep because
that was,
my cycle was terrible.
But I was like super addicted to video games and then the shooting happens and
just turned my entire life upside down.
So just completely changed me.
So at that moment,
you know,
I had to become much more mature.
I had,
I was living in the adult world,
you know,
I had responsibilities.
There are things I had to do,
you know,
I had to act a proper certain way.
And,
you know,
uh,
did you have any particular political beliefs before all this?
Because you're definitely in terms of at least the kids or the young people that
are public about all of this now that have come out of Stoneman Douglas.
I mean you definitely are the one that seems,
at least that I know of is,
is the furthest right that is sort of embraced conservatism and all that did,
is that where you were politically
you think about anything about me?
Um,
my parents aren't political at all whatsoever,
so all my political beliefs I've developed myself,
uh,
and how I develop every single political belief is just,
I look at it straight from a rational,
logical point of view with no emotions whatsoever.
I think you can guess I'm not an emotional person.
So like I think with,
with legislative decisions,
you have to put emotion as far out of it as possible.
You have to do policies that,
that actually solve the problem,
not just make you feel good.
So I'm,
I'm really not,
uh,
not for like feel good policies.
We care about politics at all before any of this or is this new?
Yeah,
I did care.
The 2016 election I was,
I was somewhat into it after the election.
I kind of didn't care as much,
but I was always like somewhat of a second amendment supporter.
Um,
yeah.
But when I,
when I started speaking out,
so what's really interesting,
uh,
it was like a tidal wave of opposition.
You know,
I had,
my school was against me somewhat seem like that,
you know,
all my peers were against me and I try not to do a victim from the Taliban.
I just want to paint the picture of how it actually was.
And it seemed like the community,
the mainstream media and my friends,
you know,
it seemed like I was going against every single opposition.
You know,
I was scared like this could,
this could have ruined my life,
but,
you know,
I believed in what I was doing and I just power through it
and just really,
I just stuck to my beliefs and didn't let anyone tell me otherwise.
Cause you know,
when I was,
so when I was in Tallahassee,
uh,
when they were pushing Republican legislators to enact gun control legislation,
I said,
look,
gun control isn't going to solve the problem.
I want to solve the problem.
Okay,
I want to make sure that school school shootings never happened.
What can I do to actually make that happen?
And what can I do while protecting the second amendment?
Because I actually believe it's one of the most fundamental rights of Americans.
So while I was there,
I started speaking out and nobody cared.
Like APP.
I would go to reporters and nobody cared.
So I had to forcefully,
you know,
like talk to reporters,
say,
hey look,
I'm a conservative.
Can I reach out?
And then I managed to get a Lillian Vitor,
it's a contact with lumens that are at Fox.
And I went on Fox and I did an interview and then Ben Shapiro site and it blew
off.
But all the while,
that's the first time I remember seeing
yeah.
And all the while there was this extreme opposition.
Um,
and the entire thing that I've,
I've always had,
sorry,
were you going,
well I just wanted to,
what do you,
cause I know you,
you kind of mock the media the way I do now on,
on Twitter and just sort of what mainstream media has become and that they are
really activists and not journalists and that whole thing.
Um,
but were you shocked when you were going up to them and going,
you know,
I'm a conservative or I want to defend the second amendment,
but I'm a,
I'm a student from this school and they're just blatantly ignoring you or even,
I know this is minor,
but like I remember when a bunch of you guys were all verified on Twitter at
once,
but you weren't,
and it was with Instagram as well.
Took me like three months after everyone else.
Yeah.
And I'm not saying that that,
it doesn't really mean it doesn't matter and of itself,
but it is,
it is a symptom of sort of the broader situation going on here with tech
companies and media and all that.
Like were they flat out ignoring you?
You saw them interviewing people.
And then,
so here's here,
here's what occurred.
Uh,
the main organizers of that,
that you sealer crew with a solid group of like the march for a live kids.
At this point,
they had solidified a click and they wouldn't let anyone new or with a different
opposing view into it.
So I said,
I have to take matters into my own hand.
In addition,
we were in Tallahassee.
I realized that the mainstream media is just doing this for clicks cause can we
think about it when mashing occurs and the mainstream media loves it,
they get great coverage,
they get great amount of views.
They do.
Um,
I'll,
I'll switch,
I'll talk to it like no to writing addition after this.
But I saw that when someone,
there was a girl crying and Tallahassee and the second she cried,
just she got sworn by reporters and I saw that they were just looking for,
for clicks and for headlines and,
um,
and I realized that they're really,
they're not reading it for the right reasons and they're not gonna listen to a
rational,
irrational young kid like me.
Okay.
So in addition,
I also realized that there was an extreme amount of just,
people were just benefiting off of this so much.
Um,
so after the shooting we realized that a lot of this occurred because the
shooter who,
I try not to say his name ever cause I think that gives him to notarize me.
They,
they,
they would,
they would post.
So here's what time did.
So the video of the shooter were basically says,
you know,
I'm going to be the next school shooter of 2018 I want 20 people.
And he basically says,
you're all going to see me on the news.
So,
and then tie magazine puts this video up on Youtube.
It gets 3.6 million views.
The same thing with all the other videos,
you know,
seen and talked about this exact clip and basically just still showed it on air.
So the entire thing with the mainstream media is doing is that they're
basically,
they're just benefiting off the situation and what they don't realize that
they're perpetuating the issue and making it worse.
That's why I think daily wire of Venice doing your great decision with not
showing their names and faces because it's an ethical decision.
No,
I don't think government should impose on,
on,
you know,
on the mainstream media to not allow the show their faces.
But I think it's an ethical and moral decision that people should be taking up.
Yeah.
So just to be totally clear,
so after this shooting,
that was when Ben announced he's the editor daily wire.
They are no longer going to,
yeah,
two days after.
Yeah.
So,
okay.
So you started to see this,
this issue with the media that they're ignoring people like you and they're sort
of making other people stars and they're going for the clicks and all of that.
What about,
you know,
I don't want to make this about people per se,
but so that,
that little click of of kids that then was all over the media and was getting
retweeted by every celebrity and all of that,
were you trying to reach out to them at all and just have that discussion or was
it just very clear?
Yeah,
no,
that was totally,
and I still try to have that discussion.
You know,
when they first started speaking on it,
I said,
oh my God,
that's great.
Someone's speaking out.
And originally when the movement started speaking,
when it started,
you know,
remember Cameron Caskey was on the car shouting the movement wasn't an anti gun
movement.
It was an anti school shooting movement.
And I said,
hey guys,
this is quickly,
I just,
I was like,
I gave him the morning guys,
it looks like you're moving through the direction of an anti gun movement.
And I don't think that's beneficial at all.
So here's my point of view.
I tried communicating and I,
and I tried speaking on and they really didn't care in allowing me.
So I said,
okay,
I have to go solo.
And that's what I've been doing.
But I,
I've,
I've always been open to discussion and open debate.
I think it was one of the great things of our country where you can have,
you know,
open discussion,
uh,
and just free expression of ideas.
That's why I think the Kanye thing is somewhat great cause regardless of what
you think of the person or celebrity,
um,
I'm,
I'm not,
I'm not in favor of propping up celebrities and their political opinions simply
because they're famous.
But you don't need a lot of political expertise to say that I believe in free
expression,
free thoughts.
Right.
That's,
that shouldn't be a really controversial position to be,
to be staking out.
All right,
so you mentioned Cameron and you know,
I had him on the show a couple weeks ago.
He's going through a very interesting evolution right now.
I suspect I can figure out where this is going to end up,
which actually be much closer to your position than the position that he's sort
of at right now because I just continually see that as the evolution of things.
The more that he understands rights and all of those things.
But I was happy to hear his thoughts and all that and look,
he sat down with me,
he sat down with Shapiro and I think he'll continue to do that.
Um,
have you guys been able to make any piece with some of this stuff or you must at
least be enjoying the fact that somebody kind of coming around?
Yeah,
no,
I think,
I think Cam's a good guy.
I think that we're seeing right now is that he's matured.
I mean,
we've all made so mean camp have gone through like the same political slash
media experience so we can understand each other.
Uh,
what happened with Kim as like,
look,
we've all made mistakes.
We've also had stuff we don't want to,
but he's matured and I've also matured.
Uh,
and what I see,
what I think is happening with Cam,
it's,
it's a natural progression of just having logical thought instead of emotions.
And I think logic and facts moves you towards the political beliefs of being a
conservative.
Okay.
So all of this happens.
I think the,
the sort of rock bottom of this was that CNN town hall,
that was terrible.
Um,
yeah,
just share your thoughts on that.
So here's what happened with the CNN town hall.
So a lot of the kids that you saw there were actually flown in on a private jet
from Tallahassee.
So already at the time of the town hall,
there was a solidified group click of,
of the kids that you see now,
and they won't let anything until they actually flew these kids on a private jet
from Tallahassee,
uh,
to the town hall.
And right there it was,
it was just simply,
they were just,
it was an anti gun debate and they were just villainizing Rubio and Dana Lash
for things that had nothing into their control whatsoever.
It wasn't their fault.
And Marco Rubio was villainized to such an extreme extent,
and he's one of the best senators.
Uh,
so you've now connected with Rubio?
Yeah.
I mean,
I hate it because when people say that politicians just don't care,
it's just so wrong.
I mean,
politicians,
they do care.
Um,
and you know,
he was one of the greatest supporters of the Stop School Violence Act that we
got past.
And you just help push it and look at these senators don't want this to occur.
Tiny won't.
And just saying that politicians want this to happen is just wrong.
Do you have any thoughts on a,
what actually happened that day in terms of security or what should have
happened or should have or shouldn't have happened?
Because even now when you go back and listen,
depending on where you're getting your news from this,
it sounds,
you know,
they either step down or they didn't go in or this or that or the other thing.
And it's like,
well,
what,
what should have happened in the ideal world that you want to create in the
system that you want to create to protect this,
these schools from not having this happen again?
Um,
what,
what should happen that day?
What we saw at my school was simply an utterly just massive incompetence and
failure of law enforcement.
You know,
the sh the,
so the shooter was flagged multiple times by the school,
by the school administration.
They knew he had mental issues.
He was put into the promise program.
Um,
and they,
that this kid was a threat.
There were 76 times the police,
there were 76 times the police came to his house,
the two FBI reports,
they knew that this kid was a threat and the law enforcement was completely
incompetent at that level and they didn't do absolutely anything.
Everyone knew this kid was an issue.
What happened at school was was just utter incompetence in addition.
So when he gets on campus,
okay,
you just makes a straight beeline for the freshman building and at the exact
same time we had a school resource officer who,
who,
who heard the gunfire and came and you just hit an a corner while kids were
dying and then three unarmed individuals rushed to save three on three on when
to the building and died trying to save kids.
What we should have had,
and this is why I push for it,
the only way to stop a shooter who is active on campus is to have other people
who are armed.
The only way to stop,
it's not a cliche that you only way to stop a bad guy with a gun is a good guy
with a gun.
And in addition to that,
there's the entire idea of a gun free gun free zone.
It is utterly stupid.
Yeah,
it is just completely stupid.
All it's doing is enticing a target saying,
look,
you go here.
So here's,
here's what's the school?
The average response time from police station to a school nationally is 15
minutes.
The average time of school shooting happens is five minutes.
That means the shooter has 15 minutes to do whatever he wants.
If the school was a gun free zone.
So here's what I'm saying,
at least allow teachers who have gone through the proper training,
you know,
ex military ex law enforcement to be armed.
Because what that does is it sends not only a message as a deterrent to a
shooter that says,
look,
this school is armed.
If you get in here,
your brains are going to be blown out.
It also says that,
that the school wasn't a gun free.
The school is no longer a gun free zone.
So I'm with you partly on that.
So what I would,
maybe,
maybe you can explain this a little bit further so I don't know that I want guns
in those classrooms.
Even if it's,
Oh,
here's the license.
Here's the interesting thing.
There are 25 states where teachers can be armed in,
are armed in schools and all the hypotheticals that are pronounced.
It's like,
you know what,
if a teacher shoots a student,
when there's another like,
like what if there's a school shooter and a teacher gets shot and there was a
gun on the floor?
What does the student do?
It's these hypotheticals don't happen.
25 states where teachers already armed and it works.
So why not just have them have security guards at specific?
Oh,
a mansion.
So here's the thing,
I'm all for having security guards.
This entire issue is how do we best manage our funds and secure our schools.
The thing with law enforcement officers is that they cost a lot of money and
impoverished schools are ready need that funding for materials.
And in addition,
it does not take a lot of training and a lot of money to have a teacher to be
armed.
And this has already been proven to work.
And in addition,
when you have teachers who are armed,
the shooter doesn't know who it is.
If you,
if it's a law enforcement officer,
you can clearly see who it is.
So if you've one resource officer,
school resource officer who's armed,
the shooter comes and takes out the school resource officer and then they're
free to do whatever.
Yeah.
But it's simply,
so here's the thing.
Simply giving teachers to have the opportunity has a massive effect because it's
up to their own will to do.
So they have to go through training and they have to,
it's a concealed carry.
So nobody knows they have them.
So as you said before,
you like facts and logic.
Okay.
Yeah.
I'm strictly facts.
Facts don't care about your feelings.
All right,
I got you that,
that,
that works.
When,
when you've engaged some of your friends and other students about these ideas,
I mean everyone watching this at this point knows that so much of what's coming
out of the modern left is about feelings and all of these things.
Do you have a sense that they understand that young people,
at least the ones you're talking about,
understanding like what rights are,
what,
why,
why we should care about these things,
why free speech matters,
why the second amendment matters and things of that nature.
So,
or does it all just sound good to them?
And there's a,
that's pretty much,
it makes them feel good.
You know what they push and makes them feel good by their emotions.
That makes sense.
So here's the thing,
I am very scared of lowering the age for people to vote to be 15.
Like that scares me because the kids that I know who are 15 know absolutely
nothing about politics.
I think I know like the kids from the march for our lives better than I think I
know their own arguments better than they know their own arguments.
Like I can argue for them better than they can do.
So I strictly use facts only.
Um,
so when I make an argument with them,
I cannot really know what they're going to do next.
So here's how I'll give you like a 10 minute or five minute recap.
Basically how I premise the second amendment argument in America,
we have the right to bear arms and DC versus Heller.
That right rule that an individual's right to arms,
it doesn't mean the militia,
the militia clause is different from the individual,
right to bear arms.
That means that you personally have the right to arm yourself.
Okay?
There are about 270 million guns in the United States.
15 million.
Those are air fifteens.
So we look at the gun stats are 33,000 annual gun deaths,
66% so two thirds are suicides.
So leaves us with 11,000 gun deaths a.
So we have to,
so in addition to put in parentheses,
there's a difference in a homicide and a murder.
So homicide is just a killing a murderer is an unlawful killing and gun stats,
a lot of them like to perverse this into skew statistics.
So 3% of all gun deaths are with rifles.
Okay?
And in that 3%,
68% of those are suicides.
So 1% of all gun,
that's their actual,
uh,
murders,
or actually,
sorry.
Yeah,
we're actually murders with rifles.
Uh,
80% of all gun crime related activity is with illegal firearms.
most schools,
most shootings or with pistols.
So,
so march for life has five bullet points.
Uh,
one of them is like,
I don't talk about,
they like to talk about the CDC and we should allow the CDC to do research.
The issue with that as the CDC has already proven to skew statistics and to not
actually provide good research.
What research is it that they want?
The CDC,
the CDC used to be able to do research on gun violence prevention and just
figure out what's going on.
But it's been proven time and time again that they screw their statistics with
Fargo and was like,
no,
we're not allowing you to patch,
wait a false myth.
Uh,
so a myth,
uh,
so basically they stopped funding.
The next thing is that they want high capacity magazines.
Uh,
there is no distinction there.
There was no difference.
That shows that high capacity magazines,
whatever that means he can do more damage as simply having more like clips.
Um,
just having smaller,
having larger clips,
but less of them.
There's no distinction that actually does more damage.
The next thing that they want to do is ban semiauto rifles.
As I've said before,
only 3% of all gun deaths are with rifles.
So banning them does absolutely nothing addressing the issue in lowering,
uh,
gun violence is making sure that we have,
making sure that we have more people who are armed because there's a direct
correlation,
not causation,
but correlation that when we increase firearm ownership and concealed carry
permits,
in addition,
um,
violent crime goes down.
So the next thing they like to propose is what about Great Britain and
Australia.
So in Great Britain,
there was a,
there's a ban on guns.
It immediately after violent crime spiked,
uh,
and in addition,
you have armed robberies,
um,
increased.
So violent crime increased immediately after,
and burglaries in Great Britain,
uh,
60% of them occur when the individuals at home versus 13% of the u s so burglars
have admitted that they do this because they know that the person will have like
the purse or whatever and they won't.
There'll be on arm.
So violent crime spike.
The next thing is I say,
hey Kyle,
what about the Australian gun by program?
So already in Australia when the program was initiated,
there was already statistical zero,
uh,
for,
you know,
gun death and public mass public school shootings.
Um,
so in addition,
when the buyback gets implemented there already,
we're like their millions,
millions less guns in Australia than there were now.
So the gun buyback grows in,
only one third of guns get taken.
And when we saw immediately after the buyback was that violent crime spiked.
So here's just the basic argument,
there is not been one single occurrence where gun control gets passed and,
and,
and gun deaths,
no,
sorry.
Gun homicides actually decreases at a faster rate.
In Australia,
the gun,
the homicide rate was already decreasing in a really good rate.
It gets passed gun control and the rate stalls.
So it actually hurt in addition to immediately after it was passed to violent
crime rates go up and the national trend was going down.
So the gun buyback program was completely ineffective,
did absolutely nothing.
And then it failed on such a huge level in Australia that implementing it in the
u s with 270 million guns simply won't work.